I feel like I'm kind of my head coach in
a sense where I structure my all my
workouts
and he'll take a bucket if there's two
chicks he'll take the ugly ones
that's what you need now I will say this
have you ever used his Carnival
connections because he grew up in the
carnival to like bring in Grapplers like
but instead of a grapple it's like
someone who could rip a phone book and
have like just extreme strength yes does
he bring other retards in from the
carnival yeah we need a spawn partner
no but no Tim Tim
no I will say I think Tim pretty much
you know won me in my last fight like
there's the eclipse of going into the
second round where he gave me very good
advice and changed the course of the
fight my whole team is just so [__]
solid that I believe you know everyone
kind of says I have the best team I
really do believe I have one of the best
who builds the team for a fighter I'm
like actually actually I want to go back
even further I want to go back to the
beginning you grew up in Montana did not
see that coming yeah I mean okay
you don't want to go to college you
decide to go to Phoenix and why Phoenix
yeah I didn't want to go to [__]
Elementary School I remember
because like the half days in
kindergarten I just like I hated school
from day one from kindergarten is
coloring dude yeah
I didn't I didn't like School in general
uh in high school I love sports
basketball football soccer and I soccer
basketball football in high school I
like soccer but then I turned like eight
and I was like yeah
that's what it was a cardio wasn't there
it couldn't run exactly
you're in America
looking now
good grades to play basketball and
football what what type hey [__] yeah
yeah
I didn't like school I didn't like that
stuff so I went to kickbox I just went
to a random we went to a kickboxing gym
in Montana in Montana Montana kickbox
it's very low level as far as like you
know and I didn't know that at the time
so I'm [__] fighting I'm knocking
these dudes out that guys that just
absolutely suck but I have this
confidence I build this confidence which
is really important for young Fighters I
believe is to gain that confidence so I
was knocking these guys out
um you know fast forward I'm you know 18
and Tim invite men bites me to Arizona
Tim finds out about you yeah Tim's from
Great Falls Montana he's an hour away so
I didn't know him he fought on Bellator
Fight Master it was like this TV show
I'm sitting in my living room I'm like
what the [__] that guy's from Montana
like yeah I could do it I wanted to be
famous and I want to be rich and I
wanted to get chick that was my main
motivation going up what's the [__]
like in Montana yeah
yeah it was you know I was
if I lost my Virgin I was 16 16 to 18. I
pulled I was probably like my heydays
really really
no but Tim invited me he went down to
Great Falls he was already living in
Phoenix I had a fight I was 18. I beat
this kid Tim said if you want to come
and train to the real gym in in Arizona
let me know and uh I hit him up like the
next day I came down to Arizona got
literally for 10 days every time I left
practice I was crying did you think you
were gonna get your ass kicked like that
did you think I did not yeah I didn't
think so okay so you're going into this
gym are you sparring or you do are you
doing kickboxing [__] where like
everybody spars in the same room yeah
they that's like you ever see like
Mexicans play basketball in a pickup
Court
know oh there's like 17 of them playing
like three on three and four on seven
like there's no like rules that's what
kickboxing sparring looks like to me a
little bit now that you say I can
picture that yeah yeah uh I I did that
when I first got down I feel like you're
not picturing enough because it's really
fun yeah if you're really picturing it
you're dying laughing but yeah you see
it like you know obviously of like in
boxing traditional sparring is there are
two dudes in the ring everybody's around
the ring waiting to get there around and
whatever but kickboxing is this group
yeah it's like sweaty everyone's
grunting yeah it's a sports orgy yeah
yeah it's changed it's changing a little
bit I well growing up or coming up you
have to do that you gotta kind of just
get your rounds in yeah you gotta
probably like comedy you gotta just do
it you got 100 yeah you gotta go beat up
you gotta [__] take your lichens and
uh so you got your ass kicked a lot
every single kickboxing and then when it
came to wrestling I didn't know how to
[__] wrestler save my life so
everyone and kickboxing I would do okay
I would do all right but when it came to
like grappling days I had zero chance so
I would leave the gym [__] crying
like God damn it this is not kinda where
are you sleeping guys important tour
announcement I just want to say thank
you guys so much for selling out all the
shows in Phoenix man that was crazy
um Gary Indiana
sold out uh Temecula sold out Reno we
just added another show man so go get
the tickets for that while it lasts and
of course Calgary uh tickets still
available for that show up there and uh
we got some more show analysis coming
very soon so stay tuned once again thank
you guys so much uh for for getting the
tickets to the show and get them early I
see scalpers raping people for ticket
prices out there so get them early on
the announce I don't want you to get
beat over the head by these scalpers
um and yeah the andrewsoft.com thank you
guys so much man peace
Tim and I I was staying at the first
time I came down here I was staying at
Tim's apartment this [__] yeah in
this shitty apartment and it was uh
yeah were there any Carney creatures in
there it's a one yeah uh but yeah so I
moved I went back to Montana [__] the
uglier girls because
he was raised with like bearded ladies
and [__] so maybe it's not that bad for
him yeah I mean
I don't I think he's like feeling like
the man so if like some chicks giving
them the thing is he's got a really good
looking girlfriend too so he can't pull
some good good girls yeah but he will
take the one that's not so good looking
for the team he says yeah really but
it's team 10 yeah
it makes him feel more comfortable if
they're like a little bit he's like a
Ross Shopper but with women yeah
I remember when I was younger I went
down Argentina I couldn't get live to
save my life and by the last night I was
looking I was looking for a girl with
like a small deformity that most people
like a shorter leg no no finger missing
sounds good I was like look at girls
hands and see because if it's a pinky
nobody's gonna notice my dick will look
at least this much bigger yeah and then
like and but she knows yeah that she has
nine things yeah yeah yeah so did you
find anything no but I found a girl that
uh was fat but she had one of those
things that
that's what he was grabbing he's like
one of those uh one of those dicks and
then they get hard it's so much more fun
uh yeah no no she just had one of those
like um Slims or whatever whatever yes
so and and when when I took it off I
mean the seams were like tearing it's
like open up one of those mattresses
they ship you yeah
yeah it was an insane situation yeah
anyway so it still took it down
yeah Argentine is known for their meat
dude come on
did he dye your hair is that what it was
that's where it started he's like
welcome to the carnival dude no not
quite not quite but yeah so I went back
to Montana for like probably less than a
year worked full-time saved up two
thousand dollars and packed my car and
drove to feed what were you doing what
was the job it was actually really fun I
worked at a mentally disabled group home
with so there's eight of them
yeah
he's like I just need more gym time
baby
did you [__] up any of the dudes or no I
drove the short bus though no no yeah
that's kind of something I like to tell
people that's fire dude so I would drive
I'd bring him to work kind of like peace
out work yeah they worked just like drop
them off
yeah bro what do they do they're like a
paper place like they just look [__]
sort paper I don't know what they
actually did I didn't go in I dropped
them off and then I came back I picked
them up and this kind of helped them do
their chores because they were some of
them were like a little bit more they
could do some [__] some of them really
needed help one of them would [__] in
this peanut butter jar and put it up in
his in his room
that was [__] up yeah extra crunchy
yeah I didn't find it but someone else
did they're like why is your room so
like [__] so bad and they put them up in
like little tiles he'd [__] in a peanut
butter jar put it on [__] put it yeah
that's why you started examining your
[__] yeah
it's like mostly chips
so [__] in a peanut butter jar put it up
in the towel so nobody knows and it
would just stink up his room I don't
think he looks [__] I think he was
Evil Genius yeah but that was actually a
really rewarding job I really liked that
um but yeah save that money moved to
move to Phoenix Tim and I ended up
getting can I ask you a question how
much do you make being like a yeah a
Wrangler I didn't want to say it yeah
yeah how do you do it um [__] that was
probably 10 years ago I was probably
making minimum wage I don't remember I
think I made like
a month price something like that wow
400 a week something like that to to
really
keep yeah together yeah just drive the
short bus yeah yeah wow underpaid
underpaid yeah yeah great job honorable
job for my passengers to the driver
that's great yeah if I had to go back to
work right now I'd probably go somewhere
around there though for real those guys
hanging out with those guys like hang
out with Tim all day
you feel at home
but yeah move to Phoenix Tim and I got
an apartment so you have two thousand
bucks that's it two thousand dollars
saved up
um luckily in Montana they really did
kind of it was like you know they really
supported me there was a couple like
sponsors that I could get that would pay
me like a couple hundred bucks a month
and at the time two 300 bucks a month I
was like [__] yeah that was that's going
to this bill that's going to this bill
so I never actually had to get a job
when I moved to Phoenix I was never
trained twice a day which was [__]
huge right uh so Tim and I got a dumpy
ass apartment and I only had known Tim
for those 10 days that I came down now
we're you know moving in together my mom
did my laundry dishes like did I didn't
know how to live on my own and uh Tim
had already been living on his own so
he's like what the [__] this kid doesn't
know [__] he's like having to tell me
like hey dude you gotta [__] wash
your bowl yeah yeah you just [__] in the
toilet not the jars like yeah it's the
whole thing yeah pretty much so it was
some learning curves there but yeah we
lived together for for a couple years
um and and at the time his goal was
getting ufc2 so we were just training
living that kind of like fight fighter
so there's a question from before this
when you're in high school you said you
knew you were going to be famous when
between like 16 and 18 right that was
the goal I thought you basically had
like a revelation like oh this is gonna
happen for me well actually I feel like
I was younger even
like Middle School I remember well I
thought I was gonna be in the NFL until
I realized that was white
no I want to be in the NFL a super
delusional I'm from Montana Helena
Montana is like 17 [__] people there
so I didn't realize like that's not
realistic want to be in the NBA you know
yeah and realize that's not realistic
can I start kickboxing I was naturally
pretty good at I was athletic and uh you
know I do believe some people are just
[__] born Fighters some people's not
a fight and I just it kind of clicked
for me it's like that's it that's how
I'm gonna that's how I'm gonna do it
were you street fighting and stuff like
no I never I didn't I didn't like
confrontation I didn't I didn't like
confrontation I didn't like street
fights I avoided it but really like I
wanted to get chicks money and fame like
that was like the three things yeah
that's yeah now you're in Phoenix okay
you're living with Tim you're learning
how to be an adult yeah you're doing all
these things Tim is also trying to be in
the UFC yeah you guys ever Spar no he's
a lot bigger but just for funsies
um just [__] around grappling more so
like jitsu wrestling yeah but like [__]
them up a little bit no wash my bull
[__]
opposite then no Tim was always he was
good and uh he was cool but he was
Jehovah's Witness too so he had to Ben
like yeah how did they react when they
knock on the door how does that's a good
question
[Laughter]
yeah
didn't even try to get you in were you
ever like yo let's start knocking yeah
no door-to-door no who's out at that
time but uh
yeah okay so you guys are in Phoenix
it's starting to happen you're getting a
few hundred bucks from these sponsors in
Montana
um family is supportive of this you're
starting to get better I imagine you're
starting to get the better end of these
exchanges with the kickboxing guys in
Phoenix after years like I didn't go
down and it was like all right I'm
starting to it was like there was years
how old were you when you felt like all
right now um now I'm getting dude
there's still there's still guys that
are like give me troubles there's I mean
we're at such a good gym you know I
trained Tim has his own gym in the MMA
lab in Phoenix there's guys in UFC like
they're they're still got and I'm never
if you ever go to a gym you're just a
[__] man you're not the wrong gym
right right so there's still guys that
give me trouble all the time so we
constantly are evolving at each other
right but yeah for there was a couple
years to where I was like kinda I knew
it was long I was athletic and I could
learn I was like if I go just keep going
keep going keep going I can get good and
then there was a time where I'm like oh
okay I started getting better because I
took it more serious like there was guys
that would like work kind of they would
work then go to the gym once a day I was
going twice a day and my main focus was
was becoming the best I could so you
know after a couple years I started
catching up as far as skill wise so some
people usually break down right when
they reach a wall right they go okay I'm
not good enough I can't do it what was
the thing that made you push past that
I think it was the chicks and the money
it was like that's stronger that Hunger
for More yeah
um pretty girls in Phoenix too yeah yeah
that's true curious what did Tim see in
you that he's like uh even though he's
getting washed in the gym I'll still let
him live with him yeah well I think it's
actually even before that he saw before
he saw me when I was 18 in Great Falls
when he was commentating before that he
actually had some 16 kickboxing in
Helena we never had any conversation I
didn't know that until you say oh [__] I
remember watching you kickbox when I was
16. I I did really good and then 18. I
knew like one thing of Jiu Jitsu it was
like an arm bar off my back and I had
fought this college wrestler that Tim
knew he's like oh this guy should beat
Sean he didn't know me very well at the
time or at all and I [__] arm barred
this dude and Tim was like damn wrestler
yeah I brought this wrestler and Tim at
the after party thing he's like hey if
you want to ever come down that's when
he asked me if I want to come down so he
just offered it he had offered a bunch
of like other people too I he said I was
the only one that like kind of took it
up I was the only one that really kind
of you know took it to them let's do it
I called him the next day I'm like when
can I go now he's like holy [__] chill
out yeah so uh yeah okay so you're
starting to get better yeah
at what point are you analyzing the
fight game
and going this is what I have to do to
be successful outside of just being a
great fighter because we know there are
great Fighters but they can't sell a
ticket
and their careers are kind of stagnant
because of it and sometimes they fall
out and there are guys who are great
Fighters that also have a personality
and find a way to get people invested
you're getting your ass kicked at the
gym are you still analyzing how to have
that Persona that can Garner interest
and money it's a good question it's so
weird I was so delusional when it came
to like I thought I was because before
Connor
no one could really kind of done that
yeah and I was thinking I was going to
be that guy I thought I was just going
to be I thought I don't know why I had
to know how to steal your [__] that's
what I'm trying to say yeah no I was I
thought I was gonna get in the UFC and
just be this [__] celebrity character
like celebrity athlete for whatever
reason I don't know I didn't think I was
like how I knew I was knocking people
out and cool in a spectacular fashion
like I didn't know if it was gonna be
that my good looks
I didn't know I just thought I was gonna
be the [__] man for some reason I
really don't know why uh but as far as I
started to kind of build a Persona and
like try to sell tickets and you know be
someone that people want to care about
probably was
probably like right before I got on the
contender series when Snoop Dogg
commentated did you see that that's that
[__] kind of like he started tagging me
on Instagram that's when I started
getting a couple followers or like five
thousand followers like oh [__] and like
I kind of liked that I was like oh cool
uh and that's kind of like
yeah when that started and then do you
is it a calculated decision to lean in
do you start going I have to be more
vibrant I have to be bigger I have to do
these things with my hair does it
organically kind of happen because
everything else in your life is
incredibly specific and disciplined and
it is a choice for optimization right
yeah so I'm assuming the same thing is
happening with your persona that's
happening with your stool
I'm sure you're like how can I extract
the most of this how can I be the
biggest yeah it's funny too because I
grew up my dad was a detective so
smoking weed was like
I was terrified even in high school like
if my if the guys were I was like
avoiding it I wasn't around it I thought
it was horrible like I thought it was
bad so when I when I moved when I moved
to Phoenix he was like take a [__]
puff yeah and I did and I remembered
like that first time I would laugh and
I'm like this is what I was scared of
like I just laughed and I'm always go go
go go go go go go go so at night I'd
smoke and I'd be like I kind of chill
out yeah I was like 19 which I don't
recommend I would I'd suggest if you are
gonna start smoking you haven't wait
till you know I think you're fully
developing to make 25 yeah 23. so I
wouldn't recommend because I know some
people that smoke too much weed and
they're [__] yeah yeah but uh yeah so
I started smoking weed and then when I
started smoking weed I had always had
this like I always thought like it was
this horrible thing so when I started
smoking I I wanted to tell people like
whoa It's not this bad thing so I
started kind of posting on my Instagram
and that's yeah it kind of just kind of
went from there and then I really don't
even smoke that much I smoke every day
like every night I'll hit my [__]
[__] bag or a King Palm or something
I'll smoke and it'll be you know once at
night but people think I [__] smoke
all day sometimes I make funny ass
videos all day just daily yeah yeah it's
very different but uh you know so I kind
of got this Persona like almost a huge
pothead and that's kind of where it came
from because when I do smoke I make a
funny ass video on Instagram like for a
brand deal yeah yeah and it'll you know
do great and that's just what people
think I do all day yeah which is which
is good yeah hey [__] it yeah yeah
there's a lot of people out there that
smoke yeah and now they're interested in
their fighter yeah yeah exactly exactly
was that the time you kind of were like
[__] with different drugs too like
mushrooms and [__] like that back in the
day yeah I I definitely had done
anything like until I moved to Phoenix
and yeah so Tim influenced me to do
drugs so
[Laughter]
we went out for his birthday to this
country bar we don't we don't go out
very often his birthday I think he's
like 32 or something he tried to [__]
the mechanical bull again
we might as well
I got this one don't worry
so we went we brought all the boys out I
have a group of guys that I met on Xbox
yeah and they all moved down to Phoenix
and I have a house that I rent out to
him and they [__] live in that and
there are boys for like two years now
it's funny as [__] they met them gaming
I met them Halo characters Call of Duty
oh they're [__] characters Smitty six
seven he's [__] Brendan's his best
friend he's five foot they're just
opposite but there's four of them that
live in this house we take I take them
out every once in a while so we went out
for Tim's birthday Tim it's very poor
decisions and now it's sick
he's so congested oh yeah that's the
worst that's me immediately after I
drink just like sinus infection yeah
especially beer if I drink beer I wake
up just congested yeah allergic to it
probably yeah
yeah so to me it's a bad decision she
didn't he couldn't make it he comes in
Friday afternoon but I know you're gonna
be in Phoenix next week
I'll go bust you guys ass in some Call
of Duty if y'all want no you won't he's
literally never played no you won't I've
also never lost